hi guys i'm ava morse and i'm the voice
of miriam i'm maitreyi ramakrishnan and
i play priya i'm hayne park i play ebby
hi i'm sandra oh i voice ming and i'm
rosalie chang and i play maylin lee and
we're here at buzzfeed to find out which
turning red character we are
all right first question first if you
were like may which animal would you
want to turn into a giant dog a giant
cat a giant hamster a giant squirrel a
giant hedgehog or a giant rabbit
isn't a giant cat just like a tiger
no no i think i'd say it's a cat but
giant
okay like a regular tomcat but giant
okay i was just wondering if there's
like lip balls in this not bad
i feel like i would not want to be a
giant hedgehog because oh i chose that
oh
because like they're very spiky and if
you're giant the spikes are just gonna
be even more big and since you're
stressed and angry i feel like i'd have
a breakdown and just end up rolling
everywhere and hurt people in the
process and i wouldn't want to be cute
i'm going to go giant dog because i like
dogs i'm going giant rabbit i'm giant
cats all the way having like a cat
island is like my retirement fever
dreams
i was gonna say giant squirrel but then
you you're reasoning with a giant cat
oh giant cat choose a pixar character to
be your sidekick for a day we have
russell from up woody from toy story boo
from monsters inc disgust from inside
out alberto from lucca and edna mode
from the incredibles we love edinburgh
i'm gonna
i'm saying alberto from luca because i
love luca
he's wholesome i'm edna i don't know
okay so the next question pick a boy
band to go see after you sneak out of
your parents house
we got instinct one direction bts
backstreet boys
jonas brothers and five seconds of
summer and then i got mine the second i
saw it bts yes
okay i'm 90s baby i'm nsync
if i see one direction am i seeing all
of them individually
they're not together anymore well that's
why
none of them
but if they were i'm going to do that
you know i'm going to go one direction
just to see them all together again
history and ava i said jonas brothers
i'm a big jealous brother okay i can see
that yeah yeah okay
choose something important from turning
red maize tamagotchi four town lee
family temple jin lee's cooking toronto
all of the red panda may march i'm going
to toronto four town all the way up
four town four towns
what's important to you what resonates
in your heart the music the food thank
you
yeah
gently
and finally which movie or tv show that
premiered in 2002 are you watching
tonight a walk to remember spider-man
lilo and stitch the wire kim possible
firefly spider-man yeah spider-man 2. i
love spider-man
my go-to disney movie uh i'm the wire
spider-man for me too
[Music]
[Applause]
your personality matches abby you're
rambunctious uh fierce and sincere like
abby you're a ball of energy who is
always going somewhere or doing
something you're not afraid to speak up
and say what's on your mind and you
often speak up for your friends too
you're someone who loves to have fun and
you want to make the most out of life
your passion for adventure often gets
you and your friends into some wild
situations but hey they always make for
a good story
i am miriam
your personality matches miriam you're
easy going goofy and loyal like miriam
you don't care what other people think
he and you march to the beat of your own
drum you take your responsibilities as a
friend very seriously that's true and
you'll do anything for your bffs that is
true too you're pretty a pretty calm and
relaxed person who's happiest when you
get to nerd out about the things you
love most in the world like your
favorite boy band i got miriam as well
i got your character i did get my
character out i feel like perfect
casting confirmed buttons
i got red panda man not me
i think i might be a little stressed
your personality matches yeah it's
really specifying red panda man yet
again not just mei your personality
matches red panda may you're
unpredictable confident and let's be
honest simply adorable
i don't know about that one but okay
like the red panda version of may you
love to have a good time and you're
considered the life of the party while
you can sometimes get into a little
trouble you always make sure everyone
around you feels included and is having
a blast you're a badass i'll take that
hey
i got evie
which i'm not surprised because that was
pretty much me as a teenager
angry ball of energy look at us we gotta
get a lot of varieties red pandas
that is really funny
i didn't even know that was an option i
thought it was just uh
yeah dang thank you
thank
so
thanks buzzfeed tune in to turning red
airing on disney plus
[Music]
you